what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sockin super excited
to be talking about the times are urgent
let us slow down we have dr. bio Col
Malathi joining us on the show hi bud oh
hi Alan I just so much for coming on the
program I'm inviting me I'm so excited
and grateful what a cool coincidence or
synchronicity it was that we were
finishing up interviewing Charles
Eisenstein and then you walk in the room
and he's like interview bio yep and here
we are literally the next day yes doing
the interview thank you thank you thank
you thank you and you are here from
Chennai India yes flew in from Chennai
to have a talk at the science and
non-duality conference yeah and not here
and now here yeah thank you so much for
joining us I'm so excited for those that
don't know BIOS background he is a
composer of a new cosmic language for
our times a PhD in clinical psychology
from covenant University in Nigeria
travelling professor executive director
at the emergence Network author of we
will tell our own story and most
recently these wilds beyond our fences
letters to my daughter on humanities
search for home and you can find all of
his links in the bio below bio coma off
a net also emergence network.org as well
as his books links and the Facebook page
so check all those out everyone bio we
have to start with this you write on
your website life cannot be computed in
terms of ends and purposes yet a
conversation that so many of us are
having is what is the teleology or what
is the purpose of creation what is the
point of us being here and this being
made so what how do you have that yeah
yeah how do you feel about that well the
first thing I would say to that is if I
if I had if I had a response if I had a
ready response or answer to the question
of what life is all about I wouldn't
want to know it I will do what find out
in any final way what the answer is but
here's what I'll say to that there is a
I forget the name now but there is a
people in New South Wales in Australia
and and they they have a saying
beautiful saying and it it goes like is
that there are there are 99 senses not
just five senses there are 99 senses and
one of those senses is is how do they
say one of those senses is not making
sense of the world yeah we have all
these senses but one of those senses is
just something like a black hole of
silence like like a sacrificial part of
the puzzle that will never fill and I
like that I like the idea that we don't
have all the pieces of the puzzle and
we're not allowed into that kind of um
we're not granted that kind of access so
I come from Nigeria as you have said and
some of our epistemologies invite us to
a place of surrender of noticing that
there are some things that we will never
be able to language there's some things
that will never be available for
cognition and the world is not just this
and this is a modern impulse to underlie
the world to kind of underline the
universe with consciousness and then
build up from there to say that the
deeper we go the more access we have two
fundamental meanings and principles but
the world is not entirely composed of
that which is articulable or
intelligible the world is also non
conscious we are embedded in non
conscious networks where we are
fabricated and made by things that do
not
appear the invisible as well so I think
the deeper invitation there is an
invitation to humility so to ask the
question what's it all about
that question is maybe ill posed at
worst and and the wrong question
at best it's it's we will never arrive
at a place where we finally get it
together we will practice experiment
conjure ways of knowing that will give
us some kind of stability and direction
and teleology will spring up once in a
while but it will also die and I'll have
to give way to something else so that
life is still emergent always emerging
and relational never to be stabilized in
one final place you wouldn't want to
know the answer to what is the point of
creation I I don't think I would want
you just like if you gave me a time
machine we don't want to see what
believe I want to see how maybe
dinosaurs look like or something but but
I wouldn't wanna I wouldn't want to just
figure everything out like I feel that
wouldn't want to go it may be the end
you wouldn't want to go to the end you
wouldn't want to scrub the video all the
way to the end and see what happens - I
feel something really paradoxical
paradoxical might happen if we actually
had that power like if we had the power
to get to the edge of the universe we're
not gonna find the answers inscribed in
heroed lifx on the wall of the universe
or of the Big Bang we're going to find
maybe ourselves pairing back at
ourselves I feel there's a trick there's
a riddle that is part of the DNA if you
will of reality that we are constantly
composing and by we I don't just mean
human beings and mean the vast
parliament of voices and beans and
agencies human and non-human that make
up the world so this is deeply animistic
this is deeply vitalistic this
deeply neo materialistic now the world
isn't still it is composing even maybe
that there isn't such a thing as D world
that that that is not even an issue of
multiple worlds versus one world it's a
fluid performative universe that is
alive relational and constantly becoming
alive relational and constantly becoming
yes yes so then that may be as we
discuss with Charles literally yesterday
the point is that it is alive relational
and in constant process of becoming yes
and that could be a point that could be
at one of the purposes well well the
idea of purpose itself is is is purpose
itself is conceptual it's it's a tool
right it's a strategy we need the idea
of purpose to to to train our bodies to
relate to the universe in certain ways
to take a hold of this complexity and
make sense of it so we need to think in
terms of purpose what I'm trying to say
is that the world stretches far beyond
purpose
it stretches far beyond instrumentality
it stretches far beyond language and and
which tells me that that that mystery
that if we could get the facts in tow if
we could get all the facts mystery will
still remain and maybe facts oscillate
at the speed of mystery so there there
there isn't the deeper we look the more
mystery we find that even facts are
mysterious in a sense so that so that
purpose is still mysterious I love how
you take us into a world of the
aliveness the relational Ness the in the
becomingness
and I love how you also dive us into
understanding with this idea of humility
beyond what is beyond our calculations
are beyond our senses that that is also
embedded in this creation and that by
having that bit more humility with that
it makes us feel in it's in ways a
little bit more at home but yet it makes
me want to also scientifically probe at
bat-like and understand it with
hypotheses and try and better understand
this creation that we are embedded in
although you know that actually brings
up this question about impossible we
like to say nothing is impossible mm-hmm
but maybe there are certain aspects of
creation that are impossible for us to
understand that's a hard question for us
to be able to just say what yeah yeah
you're brought to a place where you're
you learn that your tools are not
neutral or not apolitical and this has
been exploded in scientific studies and
for Locke the philosophy of science
basically beautiful insights by feminist
reiterations of scientific practice that
basically tell us that science is not
neutral it's not a historical a
political in probing the universe you
are not uncovering things as they really
are you are co-creating and constructing
and I'm biasing and and and slanting
things in a way that is available for
your observation so that so so that
science is not uncovering the world as
it is it's creating it's constructing
it's it's it's deeply political so to
speak so we then ascribe the description
to creation as we continue to poke and
probe at it that is the philosophy that
comes with empiricism and that is
already entangled at Imperial and
colonial dynamics that when i probe the
universe what I'm uncovering is truth
universal apolitical works at all for
all people and for all times this is the
foundation of of colonial
interventionism basically that your
knowledge is very applicable to yours
yes I mean whatever I found should work
for you whatever what
I found you know in Austria should work
with people the Yoruba people in Nigeria
these were all one our bodies are the
same human beings are the same
regardless of place and culture and
context and practice and and and feeding
habits we are all the same and this is
this is how modernity this is the
impulse this is the agitation of
modernity to stabilize things to name
them index them categorize them so that
it's easier for us to continue with our
world be building practices of of
stability a settlement building a
settlement we do look at something like
the molecular composition of water and
we do see it the same no matter where we
are on the planet
yes weather so there is like an absolute
truth like but but even that even that
is performative like the tools that you
use are not just neutral arbiters of
knowledge then you're not you're not
neutral passageways there are other ways
to hold water for instance to see water
as spiritual as spiritual ok so that
this is what I what gives me life it's
what gives us food it's what is part of
this beautiful cycle on the planet it's
what I bathed with right that it is so
you see it that way instead of the
molecular composition right I I can I
can use certain tools and and diffract
politically speaking water into
something atomic something I can
quantify it basically or I can approach
water as ancestor or I can approach and
these these are not less business as
these these are not less serious than
thinking of water in the so called
scientific terms they're just as alive
just as pressing and urgent as looking
at a drop of water in a microscope and
so they're not less real they're just as
real and so water is not a thing it's
not nothing is one thing water is
multitudinous is duplicitous it's is
contextual as any other thing is ok ok
I like your focus on aliveness
relationships and the
becoming alright of creation either I
love that that seems to be now more and
more reoccurring when we asked people
about creation they speak about those
concepts and I love those right um
you have this other really profound
thing that you say which really
resonates with me the way we respond to
the crisis is part of the crisis and
that resonates with me because it's very
clear that there is some sort of a root
aspect to this beautiful creation that
there is a root to what are some of the
issues that we have and potentially
purposely here so so that we can
experience this grand experience of
rising up and experiencing these
challenges and growing through them and
viewing it as something that who else
has ever went to these depths of hell in
order for these flowers to so
beautifully blossom up and these leaves
and branches to so beautifully brought
blossom up so in this example it's that
is it possible that so many of the
symptoms that we have in our world are
or we're trying to go and band it and
put band-aids on them and then more bad
things spring up from that versus
looking at the initial root cause and
the people that we've had on the show to
talk about the root cause have been
talking about it it's a it's it's an
issue that we have with art that we
forgot about our interconnectedness we
took that fall from grace we forgot
about our connection to nature that
we're disconnected from each other we're
disconnected from a sense of belonging
will you yeah riff on that point what do
you think is the root of the problem and
how are the ways we respond to the
crisis actually part of the crisis okay
well first first of all let me say that
I'm hesitant to even say we're
disconnected from nature okay yes yes
because to say that is to perpetuate the
silent myth that we actually are
disconnected from nature and nature is
the green grass outside our homes
you know the manicured lawns or the
forest the wilderness it's a
stabilization of nature - like cities
are masculine that the forest and the
wilderness is the feminine and so we're
disconnected from it it's a beautiful
story it works its strategic it helps us
think about how distant we are but I
think nature is not just I think so the
story works though it's actually helpful
the story is helpful is raining
attention to the deep sickness of modern
civilization beautiful but also it has
its risks and one of the risks is that
we tend to fetishize nature as the thing
beyond the thing outside they're not
noticing how and this this adds to that
this will help in my larger response so
when we think of nature as a thing out
there we don't notice that the cameras
around us the chairs the furniture this
is nature the what you're wearing right
now is nature Donna Harry would say
nature is who's a biologist and a
beautiful writer would say that nature
is a deconstruction of its own self
right a deconstruction of its own self
like like there there isn't a thing
called nature that is that is that is
still that is objectifying that is
honorable if you will and again I I
really feel the urge to say this the
invitation to say this it's stabilizing
nature that gives fascism its power that
gives fundamentalism its power because
if I say if I say that this is what
nature is hmm to progress along these
lines of eating the ecosystems around us
and the Commons then I can make that
claim and go everywhere and try to rule
everyone because I found out what nature
really is
so it it [ __ ] it's like a double-edged
sword it cuts both ways I'm very
hesitant to name nature as one thing to
to romanticize nature even to say that
if we return to nature as if nature
isn't a monster to her as if nature
wouldn't eat us to nature what it does
quake expires hurricane yes
nature is about this I'm very I don't
want to look through pink tinted lenses
and say that nature is this beautiful
benevolent thing nature resists
stabilization it's like water water is
not at home with itself it is fugitive
it's it's the embodiment of fugitivity
this auto fugitivity if you will it's
constantly missing itself and
reiterating itself and this fluidity is
what I would think of as the site but we
as a side of nature we so to speak but
we we tend to we can't work with that
right we're are embodied beings we will
need strategies to meet nature in
different ways and so that's why I say
it's probably helpful to to think of
nature as what that how that means you
know we are incarcerated in the city in
modern civilization so if that helps
it helps but I like your your so than if
I can get this right is that you when
you see creation the moment that you
create a symbol for nature and that is
that becomes an issue because that
creates separation yes it's due it's
even dualism is a strategy right like
like I'm not even going to say that
dualism is evil do do I
dualism is strategic it settlements post
Pleistocene needed that strategy to to
build settlements and the conditions
were available for for settling down in
a world that was finally ice-free
available for the taking if you will
help families for us to understand yes
well do yes quality and the nature these
are helpful ways exactly because the
minute we start to build a progress
narrative and say
we're moving away from dualism that's
already sequential negation and then
that's not dualism they're noticing that
separation is what entanglement does -
is is is it's probably helpful for us -
to embrace it all embrace the brokenness
and the wholeness the broken wholeness
of it all the broken whole face embrace
hold yourself at all yeah but but what
you say about the roots the yeah the
roots of of all of this is I would even
categorize it in terms of roots and I'm
hesitant to do that yet when I say that
the way we respond to the crisis is part
of the crisis I'm looking at the or I'm
desirous of looking at the at the
complex and complicated relation a
luyties between bodies and how these
create realities reinforce realities
sometimes beyond good intentions
sometimes beyond good plans and good
manifestos for instance we could we
don't notice how our technologies
influence us it's not usually part of
the conversation
I mean Interzone in the 1970s that
posthumanism came we started to become
popular in the academic world we started
to really pay attention to the
philosophy of waste and then came the in
the 1990s the crisis of the Anthropocene
with paul watson and eugene storm and
just in the last ten years having these
appendages these devices yes this is
another one of those big ones that we
just all of a sudden have now
ubiquitously in all of our pockets yeah
and it's now and it's more important now
than ever for us to be very vigilant in
in questioning our relationships with
them there you go so this goes beyond
language this is what our technology is
doing to us how are we being used by the
things that we suppose are are the
passive recipients of our using you know
how do phones reshape us and there's
this beautiful artist that I really
loved her work her name is Patricia
Puccini or something like that
and she is Australian I believe and she
had this exhibit in Sydney where she had
a beautiful made out of silicone I think
I may be wrong about all of this but she
had this this human-like figure made
that is alien familiar and alien at the
same time because this creature has
stretched limbs a huge head that is
perhaps the width of my shoulder and and
a sturdy neck or something like that and
basically this is her vision can't
remember what she called it maybe Fred
or Tom or something but her vision is if
we continue to use cars this is what we
might end up looking like in hundred
years because we might our bodies my
need to by process of natural selection
those of us who are Will Survive maybe
will be the ones who are better embodied
to deal with safety issues with cars so
she would she stretched out the femur of
the of this creature to be able to to
hold the brakes or something like that
it's just now it's no longer like the
eight-armed a person I can tight and yes
cell phone stuff and the thumbs of
people and I read it somewhere I think
it was in a psychology journal that the
thumbs of people these days is becoming
flat or something like that because we
are constantly sliding and all of that
but then all the transfers people you're
just talking about would be like no no
no we're going to the neural interfaces
I don't even get to that for yeah you're
laughs we'll get to that conversation
later my point is my point is we are
were we're hyphenated bodies and this is
a deeply this is metaphysics metaphysics
of relationality helps us see that
clearly that we are hyphenated a
agency is not human agency is diffracted
and shared agency is ecological so so
that to say that we want to solve a
problem is to assume that humans
actually solve problems in some kind of
unilateral way which is not actually the
case in my view I think that we build
technologies and technologies influenced
us in return and build us in return and
shape how we shape the world so it's
like ox imitating life imitating art
imitating life and then we're caught up
in this cycle this is cyclical vortex of
bodies that imagine because imagination
is also material that that's that
secrets imagination in a particular way
that secrets Responsive ax T in a
particular way and then we're caught in
this way of seeing the world and we
don't know how to see it otherwise and
and and there you go the crisis secretes
a solution that only reinforces the
crisis and what would we do about this
root what is the root and what do we do
about it to help us find more belonging
and more interconnectedness look well
well maybe maybe it's not about roots
then maybe it's about ruptures maybe
it's about cracks then if you take the
metaphor seriously of us being in a in a
whirlpool and we're just running around
each other maybe maybe the invitation
there is to look for cracks openings
generous discontinuities radical
discontinuities in the fabric of things
would we maybe call these some sort of
like exit doors out of the matrix
beautiful with that exit door is it the
matrix yes that that and this is not a
human thing also it's it's a it's a
parliament of things that might the ways
bodies the way that body is mix with
each other might open up a crack
somewhere
poor graphical shift that might allow us
huh you know this is why I say D :
d coloniality is not even human work
it's not human practice it's I see
deeply in posthuman terms and in post
human ways so D coloniality is not is is
is not not left to us it's not
unilateral look maybe a question then
would be is it maybe an example like
meditation arriving in the West one of
these cracks eiated a good yeah yeah I
could it could even be right here in the
technologies that we use it could be
that something quite unexpected happens
and the things that we expect to be to
be that we've already categorized as
evil maybe we even say capitalism or the
things we like Facebook could be the
occasion could be the occasion for new
kinds of bodies or new kinds of emergent
realities let me put it this way there
is a beautiful biblical passage in the
Bible passage in the Bible how it's
about Samson I don't know if you know
any Bible but it's Samson the strongman
he's uh he's on his way to a place
called Timna and on the way to Timna he
encounters a lion because he's a strong
man divinely imbued with strength he
tears this lion apart easily just rips
it apart
he's the biblical Hercules for those who
don't know Samson and then he's on his
way he continues on his path and on his
way back he finds that there's a hive of
bees a swarm of bees that has infected
the carcass of this lion and they are
producing honey and it's it's a it's a
philosophical moment for Samson he
ponders this this and says you know out
of this sweet something out of the
bitter something sweet emerges and I
like that metaphor I like that Widow out
the bittersweet emerge emerges and so
out of the in many ways some of the
worst issues and traumas something sweet
well we don't know like I read recently
about a whole the Ohio with cancer rich
Research Center or something using the
flu to cure cancer some form of cancer
you know a sickness to address another
sickness because bodies are relational
they are they are constantly potentiated
if you will with the next they're not to
be stabilized it constantly our bodies
are sacred is what I mean by sacred I
mean they move this they spill they
spill through the containers that we've
placed them in which means that the
things we've already labeled as bad as
evil and this is not an excuse or
justification for them but is to notice
that the world is much more promiscuous
than we give it that then we allow it to
be it doesn't abide faithful to our
ideologies to our manifestos to our
plans I want to give it space to be as
alive as it wants to be and so the the
things that the the kinds of spaces that
my work is about is about sitting with
all of this trouble maybe is what Donna
Harry would call stayin with the trouble
staying with the troubling emergence of
the world stayin with its flows and
movements now this is this doesn't mean
that there aren't stable or stabilizing
places it doesn't mean everything is in
flux and there aren't bodies that have
reinforced themselves over time so we
can speak of simple SS which is how
bodies become with other bodies and we
can speak about Auto Perez's which is
how bodies gain independence as well
want to hold attentions of that as well
that yes there are larger patterns that
we can speak about we can speak about
oligarchic the oligarchic dynamics in
america right now and we can speak about
how we can respond to that but we also
want to take note and
autocratic yeah yes to the chronodyne
corporate overseas and all of them we
also want to take into Cognos ins the
fact that that things are not quite
still as well what where is the space to
hold the idea that we are in a
relational posthuman universe that is
that is that doesn't won't stay still
know deeply there's no more than
vitalistic yes there's no even for one
day you can't shut the global economy
down for one day no to try and get
people to just chill for a day no you're
not gonna get that please just chill for
a day the closest we get is like
whatever Christmas or something yeah
people you know just chilling with their
families in their houses yeah yeah yes
yeah just want to get closer you want
you you wanna you want a switch off
button you want to press stop let's stop
pause let's reconsider everything that's
going on notice our inclinations to want
a stop but it might also be instigated
by the technologies that we've created
as it gives off the luxury of stopping
things now so maybe it could be the
difference you know the way we're
addressing wicked problems like climate
chaos might also be influenced by the
technologies around us the built
environment around us we want to shut it
down want to reduce it to carbon
emissions want to say that that is the
ingredient that's the cause if we can
attack this and we've solved the problem
no I think your larger issue that work
interesting although it does to me at
times feel like by feeling more
interconnected and helping people
experience non-separation unity that
then that feels like one of the major
routes alright I think it's important to
hold spaces where we we feel we feel our
boundaries coming apart and but I'm but
but it's important to notice that there
are larger bodies
that have gained resilience over time
you might go for a workshop that might
help you feel at one with the world and
then immediately after workshop is done
you're back in traffic and you don't
feel out one in a hundred
you don't feel that one in that move a
little bit more equanimous maybe you
feel a little bit more interconnected
yeah but I'm saying even the loss of
that feeling is just as entangling like
the the shock it's very difficult to
stay with us to stay because we want to
be in a miraculous high all the time
we've been life is that yeah we you you
want to be in that psychedelic high of
being at one with the universe but I
don't think I want to be in that state
all the time
I don't think I want to want to feel the
lows and the despair and the how else's
entanglement entanglement if if we're
not touching everything at once if we're
not being you know if we're not becoming
with all of that at once
you know if we're in this place of
environment this in costs this
incarceration to positive thinking
feelings about entanglement then we're
not entangled where were fetishized
beans and then utopia takes over and
utopia has a lot of consequences of
course that we can get into but the the
invitation is even the shadows even the
shadows even the shadowy places even the
cracks are part of this thing that one
refuses to be whole refuses to be
conceptually coherent for our for our
easy consumption how do we how do we see
ourselves as part of something that is
larger than language your language is
capacity to to frame this is the this is
the deep invitation of indigenous words
that I come from and the moment you're
trying to frame it go ahead try to frame
that it's a friend you don't do it try
it it's good it might work for you first
but it's risky
it comes with risks everything embodied
is risky because you move in the world
and if in some particular way you're
excluding other ways of being in the
world
I like how one person said to put on a
mask is to be true
you know you know there is some
authentic thing behind you know which is
why I hesitate to speak about this is
the root the root cause now if we can
get to this root cause then we've come
to the world as it truly really ought to
be that's another framework that's
another framework that is just as
amenable to decay as everything else is
gosh so well synthesized yeah in hearing
all of this from you and from Charles
yesterday and for more and more of the
leaders that we've been most recently
speaking to it's just so interesting to
me because I've most recently decided
that not only just are we interviewing
the greatest minds but we are also
synthesizing all of their brilliant
wisdoms right in order to try again and
I now I'm in this process of like okay
how do we use language and video and and
animations and fun ways for people to
understand the creation that they're
embedded in and it's like good luck like
that's that's but it's beautiful it's a
beautiful journey but it's also driving
me nuts and it should about the greatest
mind thing I am I think you should you
should interview grandmother's on you
should interview children who have yes
probably have nothing to offer to your
quest for great wisdom but you can find
the brilliant in some of that yes well
even in their so-called stupidity
there's a generosity of of of knowing
and being that that wisdom cannot access
and I want to be open to the so-called
stupid to the silent to to the numbness
of a table or to the to the to the
deadness and muteness of furniture
around me I mean not access stuff that I
could translate on a on a YouTube video
and say this is wisdom for you to access
to build new economies and new
educational paradigms
but but there's there's something there
maybe it's not available to us now but
the world needs the world doesn't work
by doesn't run on the engine or the
lubrication of the wise it runs on this
fluid becomingness between wisdom and
stupidity where stupidity might be
wisdom not so far out from now and what
wisdom is you know stupidity now I don't
know it's a beautiful way of saying I
don't know I really I love your your
point this is very important to I
identify the instances of grandmothers
grandfathers boys girls invisible people
don't do you have to make it that Jesus
to contact like these that you know
there's a beautiful story of Mandela
traveling through traveling through I
was still this in Morocco by a friend of
mine he said Mandela was traveling his
convoy and he stops in the village of
course in South Africa and he encounters
a woman and he says bring me some water
or something like that and she says who
are you and I'm like who are you let
just dismisses him and he's shocked
because he's Mandela for crying out loud
and but she just isn't like who are you
I don't care who you are and puts him in
a place that no one puts him in just
that simple gesture of like who who do
you think you are is is is powerful
medicine it's powerful medicine we need
in this time sure so also the way we
frame wisdom like it'll come from the
people like Bill Gates or to come from
phd's going to come from people who are
eloquent I think we need to listen to
the madman I think we need to listen to
the people outside the people that we've
brand that we've labeled as insane
Copernicus moments these yeah point one
percent idea there you go stuff like
that I think we need to we need to hold
space for that too
because yeah yeah that's where there's a
lot of generosity there totally agreed
and some of that is actually going to
end up ship
our Overton Window more and more in the
gem in the direction of progress yes
aliveness yes I want to I want to talk
about this point this is really
important to me you write about this a
lot
you had raising your daughter who's six
raising your son that's two with your
wife and your family interactions that
you've been having would this is one of
the cores of the newest book these wilds
beyond on our fences and one of the
cores of the book and also that I want
to know more about what is what is that
light because what did you learn growing
up in Nigeria and what are you doing
bringing that to your children now and
your children are in Chennai in India
yeah so what is that like and you know
and what is what does it mean the you
know letters to my daughter on humanity
search for home what is this you know he
made a search for home and just another
little bit of preface is that we've had
several guests that have joined us on
the program that have that were born in
Africa and that are doing incredible
work and it's been fascinating to me to
learn from them because there is some
sort of a different philosophical just
essence that is that's different than
West it feels so much different even
being in China just like three weeks ago
doing interviews there it was just so
much the essence between humans it feels
different what is that feeling and what
are these these these the the ethos of
your letters to your daughter and the
writing yeah okay but my first response
to that will be to acknowledge that it's
just a slight reframing that it's
because I've been doing a lot of
traveling the person that should be
credited as raising our kids is EJ my
wife my dear life partner and she's the
one cradling all of us I would agree
EJ is really and I I wouldn't even be
here without the sacrifices
she's making so just wanna lay that and
respond in on that platform yes um and
so I'm grateful for that grateful for
all the gifts that she's given us as our
modern hearth and yes there there is a
about differences there
cross cultural dynamics and stuff that
there is any time I come into the United
States I was telling my brother Charles
yesterday now anytime I fly into the
country I feel a sense of it starts from
here hmm you know they're there there's
literally a sense like there's a hanging
extra limb that's really heavy
from my throat it's a sense of dread
like I'm entering into the heart of
empire like like it it's it's part a
response a fear response
it's a fight-or-flight thing as well
it's like I is like predatory like I'm
in the in the face of something really
black and deep and and I don't know and
primal and I want to run I want to run
away but I feel I literally find myself
swallowing spit over and over again as
the plane lands and as I'm sneaking my
way up to the point where my passport is
stamped you know and I think as part of
your mission to come through
I don't know I'm I'm also hesitant to to
mission eyes my ocean
they say that's my mission is of things
yeah yeah one gets heady that way and I
and I were very reluctant to do that but
but but yes um I feel I feel there's
there there's a lot of there there
they're things that work here there i
I've said to a couple of friends of mine
in retreats that I lead or talks that I
give in the United States that that this
country I feel its greatest problem not
that anyone can speak about things in
that skill or but in some poetic sense
its greatest problem is immigration but
but not immigration that you think of
right now not the one that just flashed
through your mind I'm talking about the
immigration of temporalities that have
been erased
times that have been effaced I'm talking
about the ghosts of times and places and
bodies and cultures that that subsidize
the imperialistic Empire building
project of this country okay so are we
talking like the indigenous people of
the land not just the indigenous slavery
that was imported not just this is
slavery slavery did the the wiping out
of the massacre of the Indian people the
Native American people here the
transatlantic slave trade but the
ongoing project the ongoing project this
feels like the headquarters of the
telluric earth making machine that is
about stamping out all sorts of
ambiguity about what the world really is
and what the world really is according
to the American machine is the world
ought to be a place that serves
profit-making that serves the Commons
eating machine it ought to be a place
where we progress in this this huge
progress making machine that is called
time this militaristic mmm epistemology
that is clock time that is always
supposed to be about is we're supposed
to be these individuals citizens in the
nations in the conglomeration of
nation-states and we're supposed to to
get better at nation stating you know at
stamping down nature's insurgency
probably embodied in climate chaos right
now and then being are doing our best to
transcend and being masters of the world
America seems to be the place where that
is most held now as marching orders for
human beings across the planet and so
there there seems to be scratching on
the walls of Empire the ghosts of times
past that are still present haunting
everything that has been repressed their
spectral immigrants if you will hittin
on the gates the pearly gates of empire
saying you know we subsidize you we make
you possible I can speak in terms of it
about it in terms of in terms of people
might relate with better you know in
terms of you know this has been
incredible so far
okay well relate with this a lot and I'm
curious what you think about the ethos
of a place like China then or the ethos
of a place like Africa then that would
be this would be you know follow-ups if
that's how the spirit of the United
States know well well it's basically
what I've just said you know how we're
following Africa for instance is
following hard on on the path that
America has the trail the the trail that
America has blazed through for years now
for decades now and China is coming into
its own you know
Nigeria for instances is is establishing
very strong geopolitical economic
relations and ties with China out with
out with what what's that building
construction company now is so iconic in
America I think Julius Berger I things
called eunice Berta
it was the construction firm from
Germany to the construction firm of note
in Lagos and in Nigeria for since the
1990s in the 80s and now it's the Cee
Cee Cee Cee I think is a Chinese firm
building everything building all our
projects so they're helping us on our
path to claim development to claim our
seat
the table so we're Auto colonizing
ourselves now we're stamping down in our
own traditions with teaching more
English in our classes of course we're
holding space for our own tradition for
our own languages in some kind of
patronizing move what they were also
learning our languages and so
colonization auto colonization Wow
we're playing the rules were were we've
taken the whip and we're whipping
ourselves it's self-flagellation if you
will and and it's based on just the the
the way that in terms of the the
economic growth of the planet has
favored as the power law most of it with
the United States let's say read most
recently yeah and then the then it's
just that well now we all need to follow
similar paradigms every we have almost
no choice it's the Borden's
of the global development paradigm it's
it's 1944 Bretton Woods conference in
Washington that basically introduced the
IMF and the World Bank and made it
impossible for Africa to actually you
know be developed if you will the
architecture of oppression is in place
is what I'm saying and there is no
climbing to the top of the room the
development program will always have the
West on top and Africa following hard
behind following chasing wanting to be
part of the game when Americans speak
about the recycling culture for instance
it's largely unknown to people in the
West that most of the waste here that is
taken away from our manicured good
plastic being bins and just shipped out
to a place called far away if you know
supposedly recycled it's actually
shipped to places like Ghana exactly
shipped to Nigeria our playgrounds our
playgrounds in schools are is the
dumping site
from the West there's billions of tons
where old computer systems are just and
then we and then we take those old
computer systems and then we we recycle
them ourselves to make sense you know of
our our trash land society if you will I
believe this is also similar with the
way that boats old boats are parked on
the coast of Bangladesh and they do
similar yeah the process yeah yeah yeah
so the the justice systems in the world
the things we count as justice the
architecture of justice the architecture
of righteousness the ethics of recycling
in other ways that citizenry is
conditioned in the West is obscures the
roles that the nation state has in
keeping other people and other nations
and other societies under which is why
I'm I'm quite thrilled we're failing at
the development game I'm happy we're
failing at it recently not recently some
time ago Trump wrote about [ __ ]
[ __ ] countries or something with
specific reference to my country nigeria
like that's a [ __ ] country and as i
expected our leaders were like no we're
not a [ __ ] country we're almost like
the u.s. we have good roads and
skyscrapers and good electricity so it
was like you know we're trying to
measure up it's like phallic measurement
like we we have just as much as you guys
I felt maybe that was the wrong response
and so I wrote a letter to Trump and I
called it the surprising nobility of
[ __ ] and the idea was to say we are
actually failing at this but that's
actually a surprisingly great place to
be without romanticizing it being
intimate with our [ __ ] might help
prepare us for the tribes that are
coming you know and I'll rather be
closer to the hinterlands than the
borderlands are a lot I rather be behind
the
front runner on in a race to the cliff
edge you know you know I don't want I
don't want to be at the cliff edging and
saying I'm a superpower you know this is
where we're witnessing the dissolution
of these systems and I feel that yeah
but let me change the topic
the real question was about the feelings
so even resonant in some underground
fashion its resilient if you will it's
still a sense of belonging a sense of a
sense of community
this isn't them changing the topic this
is the topic oh well it merged at the
top this is what you wrote about the
surprising oh yeah
surprising nobility reality of [ __ ]
which is the belonging and the
interconnectedness
it's the belonging is the
interconnectedness it's the it's the to
put it metaphorically it's the
resilience of potholes
it's the metaphysics of potholes I do it
what do I mean by that its development
is smooth roads right potholes is our
failure to to maintain to maintain that
kind of paradigm they cause so many
issues with automobile tires and in
alignments and then we have to go to the
automotive dealership and actually it's
good for the economy then there you go
so I think the potholes is the
insurgency of the planet if the
insurgency of our traditions coming
across as our failure to actually
maintain these received traditions and
then we pave we pave over the potholes
we yeah yeah paving over his success is
counted as success I count it as failure
and our failure to pave over those
potholes I counted as a queer kind of
success it's like it's like another
world disk is trying to scratch its way
through and insist on being seen for
instance we had gift cultures they're
still resilient in some ways but they
have been pathologized there's a shift
right
we had gift cultures we had ways of
sharing with each other
pre-colonial societies in Africa in
Niger in what is now called Nigeria and
well these paradigms came in and a sense
of value that equated self-worth with my
individual productivity came in and then
we started to lose in those times but
those traditions are still resilient in
some ways but they're showing face in in
form of what the IMF or the World Bank
or even the Nigerian state might call
corruption today so a police officer on
this in the airport might ask you for
money as you as a foreigner coming in to
Lagos might ask you for money that's
frowned upon by the nation-state it's
frowned upon by every righteous body
institution out there that's corruption
but what if that's that's a sort of
remembering of the ways we used to share
with each other
that wasn't so bureaucratic and total
and totalizing there are always we
always appreciated each other but now in
in trying to do that it's termed
corruption its corruption just like
sharing knowledge in in in in a in a
community but the classroom context
comes in and just look over your
shoulder it's cheating it's now cheating
so the the framework of our
relationships have changed and the more
powerful dominating system is this
colonial Imperial izing we have seen the
world but still because it's not it's
not the work isn't finally done there
are still existing sensitivities that
tell us that there are other ways have
been alive even though we've quite lost
a language the way of relating to that
we know that there are other ways have
been alive and where we're itching to
find that again and those other ways of
being alive are those potholes those are
those some of my senses or thought holes
yeah as our failure and then also it's
these initial principles that
in many ways as we also had you know
Chris Ryan on the episode on the show
recently we were talking on that episode
about hunter gatherers and what hunter
gatherers had asked principals this
immediate return hunter gatherer where
you were just going taking what you need
and then moving nomadically along right
and just decide this idea of just the
way to harmonize with nature to know the
plants and the trees and the animals and
the relationships in between each other
where there's you know there's inclusive
fitness I tell you a story because I
care about your well-being and it
impacts my well-being in the whole
tribes well-being versus now it's I tell
a story because I want to get money from
you transaction transaction yeah yeah
it's um III I sense a a yearning for
those kinds of relationship matrixes
again I sense a wanting to but I don't
think it's going to be a simple return
it's never going to be a return simple
return we're so deep experimentation is
called for now that that maybe should
help us should should inspire us to be
hesitant about finding easy solutions
would it would it be fair to say that
then some of what we were just talking
about then are some of the letters to
your daughter and some of the ways that
you talked to your daughter and your son
and yeah yeah there yeah back to that
question it's I think I call my children
the children of the app Triple seen the
anthropocene been this time period when
we are all becoming homeless even those
of us who are well settled there's a
homelessness and a fugitivity that is
spilling through even modern settlements
that is saying you're not quite at home
you have to move very often the the
institutions that were your frameworks
of reference your changing as well so
we're losing trust in the nation-state
I think in America the Congress is not
as reputable it is as it once was
you know so the frameworks are hollowing
out the pillars of that are keeping
modern civil
aloft are cracking and so as they crack
we lose a sense of place and we gain a
sense of liminality a sense of
in-between us as the Nomad is always in
touch with so we become fugitive and I
think in fugitive times and times
between stories we need fugitive
epistemologies so with my children I'm
learning we are learning to to treat
them as elders and not just as
recipients of Education we're learning
to to co-parent with them to to to
effect a sensitivity to things and place
not as commodities to be consumed but as
beans that are alive in us in you know
in their own way so I teach my daughter
to take permission from a plant before
plucking it for instance or or to ask
questions like that aware that [ __ ] come
from and then we take that as research
inquiry
you know like write it down and we ask
questions and we follow ur [ __ ] comes
from or where it goes to so this is this
is the kind of education that I feel
fugitives need fugitives from a
settlement that is no longer settling
your use of the word a fugitive there so
interesting - it's just this in-between
state that it feels like we're in that
was the other word that you used I must
now then ask about this question which
it so seems like everything is in the
direction of this here we are in Silicon
Valley we recently heard a dis a quote
again from you know
Elon Musk humanity is a biological
bootloader for digital super
intelligence and everyone's like let's
build a ai ai super intelligence yes yes
yes you know that's basically the
paradigm that everyone's pushing now
around the world what the [ __ ] is it for
why are we doing it
I think we're also trying to escape it's
still the paradigm of escape do you know
that the Tower of Babel story we heard
you know that story you do okay I don't
need to tell it to you you may share
okay I'm sure that this would be
beautiful well it's not beautiful it's
unsettling it's tragic but it's also
very instructive you know after the
flood the post diluvian society decides
you know just to be secure we should
build towering structures that escape a
possible potential divine tantrum let's
escape a possible flood and so they
start to build and it's like a let's
escape the asteroid collision let's go
to Mars there you go there you go let's
escape let's just leave things behind so
if if if if God if the gods decide you
know we're tired of the human race we
can just save ourselves in in these
towers of Steel and might and fright and
and so the as the story goes every all
of mankind as the legend goes all of
mankind is one language is of one
language and the gods notice that
they're making progress actually they're
actually building these modern days
ziggurats is what they call them these
towers into the heavens and they look
down and they say let's stop them from
doing what they're doing and how they do
that is to sow confusion they they they
disturb the language the homogeneity of
our communications and because no one is
able to understand the other the
progress stops I think confusion is a
gift I think I think it's a gift and I
think that's a beautiful legend that
tells us confusion is divine it's it's
it's always part of our mattering it's
sacred I think in some senses these
transhumanist projects of trying to
attain some singularity you know
in some future time it works by many
assemblages one is the assemblage of
temporality being a linear continuity
from past present to future that this
allows us from seeing how the past is
already haunting us right now so there
is no escaping that
that's one agency the other is that we
are actually separate from our
technologies the you know the the
prophecy of transhumanism is that one
day we will gain ascendancy over all
things material that we'll be able to be
happy forever we can tinker with our
emotional capacities we can we can we
can gain complete and total mastery
that's to me that's the myth there and
it works because of this underlying myth
that we are actually separate from
nature
what if nature is using us in whatever
nature is already using us in ways that
belie and ando undercut our quests for
ascendance and mastery what if like
Michael Pollan said in his book the
botany of desire I think what if we are
the strategies of apples you know it our
perspectives are so human or centric
they're so they're so exclusive to us
that we don't notice that we are we
might be the pawns in the game of apples
we might be the pawns in in in other
life-forms out there
we're not alone we've never been alone
and that's the that that's something
really difficult for modern citizens
just dating in cities to understand
where we've never been alone and to
suppose we're alone is to perpetrate
this is is to is to is to have Elon Musk
like dreams of finally escaping to Mars
or finally gaining achieving infinite
longitude or an infinite life drinking
from the fountain of youth or something
like that
yeah man let's riff on this just a
little bit yeah yeah more we're
we're let's let let us say that as we
spoke about throughout this episode
we're doing this kind of we've been
using this now as a metaphor and I think
it's really interesting this idea of
like a boomerang that goes back and then
it fetches our initial we were talking
about this like hunter-gatherer
immediate return interconnectedness non
separation unity source adoring type
relationships aliveness becoming right
all these keywords are even talking
about boomerangs bat grabs those and
then embeds it in today's the world and
then as you embed it in today's world
all of a sudden it's not to say that
okay we're gonna stop making this and
we're gonna stop making
indistinguishable virtual realities and
we're gonna stop making quantum
computers we're gonna stop making space
settlements we're gonna stop making
super intelligence we're gonna stop
biotech and neuro tech and longevity
yeah so not necessarily stop those
things but when you do boomerang back
and you grab those these main concepts
and essentials and then you bring it to
today it definitely changes the way that
you were we were all talking about those
techno utopian yeah yeah and so then
maybe that is part of this creation of
this becoming of this aliveness yeah is
our ability to do that boomeranging
bring it back and then now recalibrate
today and then continue our process of
being builders and creators within this
creation okay this time I take a wide
berth and you know just I was saying at
the event yesterday and the conference
yesterday that I was attending that the
reason I feel one of the reasons why we
I grew up noticing that my grandmother
had things that looked like tattoos on
her arm
you know like inscriptions I couldn't
read them I didn't know what they were
about my mother told me it was a thing
of beauty
so the Yoruba people in West Africa
would this facial scarification just cut
marks into the faces is a dying trend
you would hardly see anyone with that
now because we were posh & proper yes as
the city dictates we're losing all of
that sacrificial epistemology you know
and I think the reason why we did that
was to keep a sense of rupture close
mm-hmm but a sense of crisis close that
it's it's part of pollination indigenous
traditions to to throw a man from a tree
of branch and tie with a rope you know
tied to his ankle and just toss him off
and bring him this close to bashing his
head on the ground and it's in
experiencing the intimacy of death that
he's allowed to be a fool man
you know it's in house island in Nigeria
where the BASE jumping BASE jumping a
scene of magic or say it's safe but but
there's a bungee jumping and Scott here
a bunch of bungee jumping bases I think
when you go with the wingsuit yeah okay
base base and different so bungee
jumping is the hurling of oneself but
this is without safety precautions the
wagers on roll with just a rope there's
no net to catch you on there there's no
safety net and why I'm telling this
story and yeah um but the house of
people for instance would whip a man the
community to come and whip a man that
comes to ask for a bride's hand in
marriage
whip him on to he bleeds and then he's
ready to be a man or in South Africa
send a young kid out to kill his first
lion you know that that sense of the
intimacy of rupture and crisis that
means you only live fully when you've
known a taste of death is is is what
modernity doesn't know how to hand
handle now when I hear you sing when I
hear you speak about a boomerang I hear
that and I and I say yes that makes
sense you know we want to listen and and
and adopt these practices but how do
they experientially embed them into the
the spirit of the
Alissa's when okay yes yeah that you
could frame the the the you could frame
it that way but you could also say that
there is a there is a tariff on user
friendliness about that an application
of knowledge ease and cosmologies
boomerang it back I just put it into an
app yeah let's just get let's just get
let's just get all those hunter-gatherer
philosophy let's just get all of that
routed in the how it's an apple app yeah
now is it now it's an app on Google Play
now I know I need to fill out one with
the world just feel at one with the
world app just strike that app and you
feel at one of the world I am the logic
of mastery is still this gravitational
pool that pulls down I let me reframe
that bound a boomerang curling metaphor
and the transhumanist might say
something like you pressed a button on
my phone and then I get the chemo
electro connectome sensation of
interconnectedness and then it's done
and then I feel it and I know it okay
there you go there you go
what if we allow that those the people
were hurling boomerangs at are also
hurling boomerangs at us okay
the past we're not hurling a boomerang
into the distant past because the past
isn't distant the the past the ancestors
the things that defy language are also
hurling boomerangs at us we've also been
used while also being were also being
cradled and [ __ ] were also being
scarify DIF that's a word we're also
being marked and and and disabled in
ways you know know this cause this
eternal quest for interest for for
outrageous forms of enablement is the
product of the Holocene is a product of
settlements a sense of a sense of being
a sense of being broken is is missing a
sense of being knowing ourselves
in part you know only partially is
missing you know we were striving to a
sense of completion and wholeness which
is tower the Tower of Babel you know
again we're striving for that for the
summit but I want a sense in which I'm
not saying I wanted and I'm not saying
I'm feeling entitled here but I'm saying
I'm desirous of a sense of rich in the
summit and realizing that that's the
nadir that's the that's the valley and
it's not just a climb up again is to
notice that life is not the other of
death brokenness is not the stranger to
wholeness that partiality or things only
comment in traces is just as beautiful
as things showing their full faces and
we will never have a full picture who
will never arrive we will never arrive
intact
you know we're coming down to earth
means we'll never arrive intact it's
like a libation as the water falls to
the ground it doesn't land in neat
puddles it scatters here and there to be
at one with the world is to notice that
we'll never get it completely if to be
diffracted to be at one with the world
is to let go of the idea that we can
contain control master you know he'll
gather use as we want and still be in a
position a luxurious position of of
distance in ourselves you know from how
the world matters is to allow for death
is to notice that transience and dying
and surrendering is how things work is
to let go that of the idea that
consciousness is the is the line that
cradles everything is the halo that
cradles everything and there's such and
famous you know these are great and
poetic words and it's also like you know
screaming to me there's like you know
like basil sands uh canned musk and all
these other in just ridiculously wealthy
billionaires around the planet now that
are just listening to those words and
saying famous last words
surrender and death are part of the
creation
famous last words so basically you get
conquered if you believe in yeah those
words yeah you conquered and so to me
this is like nuts daddy this is what is
yeah you know how do you feel about that
well well my people were conquered since
the 15th century they were taken and
transported over the Atlantic to New
Worlds but there's a deeper story here
that I want to share quickly that
undermines the absoluteness of powers
claim to be absolutely powerful if that
makes sense let me let me put it this
way that yes we were conquered yes this
modern paradigm is said to have defeated
a more grounded natured down-to-earth
way of living but not quite that's not
the only story that can be told Chinua
Achebe a very famous Nigerian writer he
wrote the book thing fall apart he said
until the Lions tell their own stories
the tale of the hunt will always glorify
the hunt enter so there's another story
to be told about those movements those
forced migrations and one of those
stories that I'd like to tell is that
even even in the opening of our bodies
in the cotton of our bodies as our blood
was spilt it infected the colonizer the
colonizer was undone in the moment of
undoing us so that in unzipping our
paradigms in unzipping all of that he
was infecting himself as well damn so so
so so this is what might be referred to
in quantum terms as quantum
indeterminacy the complementarity of
things that the irony of absolute power
is that immediately you establish
relationship which that which you claim
is inferior to you you've already you've
already opened yourself up to the wound
of relationality and your power is now
relational it's now indeterminate who is
powerful and who is not
for because those bodies became
creolized bodies they became the
creolized bodies in Brazil in Cuba in
Jamaica those bodies undid and and on
the cot the the Christian epistemology
is that framed God as supreme because by
bringing those slaves in they came with
their own traditions they came with
their own ways of being that became
hip-hop that became the Washington
Monument as I explained yesterday at the
conference it it it in in in cotton
yourself and I think any forensics
criminologist might tell you this that
in in slashing others in trying to kill
others they look for the these
self-inflicted wounds that the murderer
has maybe this is such an interesting
way to put it it's very relatable yeah
that you you see the the the pain that
the Persie adult on their arm has been
committing them yes yes so in entering
the colonizer and the colonized entered
into Schrodinger's box and who came out
alive is still up for grabs the jury's
still out
this is not to dismiss the painful
realities of colonization is just to say
that that's not the only story power is
much more intractable is not as neat and
as controllable as we would have it be
yeah I I'm very interested in in that
exact phrase because it does feel like
there's this continuing desire for this
neat and controlled super intelligence
that all the billionaires and soon to be
you know trillion dollar companies and
even more there's gonna be more and more
the pies growing and we're gonna conquer
celestial bodies and there so you know
it's just um
there's something about it that
feels like like you described earlier
where creation is also doing the
boomerang to us not us just going back
to the creation boomerang and grabbing
it but yeah that's so cool okay
um there's two questions that I asked on
the very end of the episode there's
plenty more of these that we're gonna
have - right right right
rounds and conversations are so good the
two questions that we like asking at the
very end of the show are the first
question is do you think we are in a
simulation no I don't know I know I know
I'm very again but everyone would have
heard me say this over and over again I
think you you could drink on drop if you
were betting on me saying hesitant then
you'll be probably rich by now watching
this video I'm very hesitant and
reluctant to subscribe to the idea that
our simulation but because I think what
it does that kind of reality framing if
oh my goodness it's just another layer
away it's like in order to distance
ourselves from from the materiality of
matter we index or we codify this other
layer of relationships we call language
and language is supposed to mediate
between us and the world now this seems
to be an extra layering like which it's
it just seems like we treat again like
it's not just language it's psy
Malaysian it's it's ones and zeroes so
in some sense we are we are twice
removed from the real we're twice twice
removed from climate change so if you
want security and this is probably the
logical outcome of contributions like
this if you want to escape then we treat
in to the luxurious confines of Silicon
Valley you know retreat to ones and
zeros to bits
and and and
and whatever and computer simulations
and all of that we treat to this to this
place we can control and handle so is
still the logic of mastery again I don't
think anyone could say I found the
answer because I like I said I think
reality is is how we move through it
there's no external position we can
stand on and say this is the world
because insane this is the world were
part of the world to move through the
world is to make knowledge in the ways
that we move there's no external point
of view Chinua Achebe against it would
say in response to Archimedes you know
Archimedes said give me a place to stand
and I shall move the world and to not
have a response there is no place to
stand we move though with the world at
its own pace so there's no external
point of view I feel this is the another
doubling down on bio determinism it's
not a doubling down on the metaphysics
of of escape the metaphysics of human
exceptionalism its layering again
distancing ourselves from from if we can
layer again another another matrix of
control over the planet then we can
secure ourselves in psychologically
economically politically we can tell
ourselves that were home we're safe so
this is home
seeking hmm but I think we need to yeah
sigh Malaysian are seeking home you know
simulation as migratory migratory
politics we're trying our desire to do
all of these godlike technologies we're
seeking home seeking home and I don't
think they're there and we will find we
will build home we built home in terms
of modernity and I think the time is up
the battery is dead and and and we can
keep on trying to change the battery but
maybe the insurgency of the invisible is
not so strong that the battery is not
just a battery we can't just put it in
another battery which we're trying to do
with sustainability with SG G's and new
Development Goals you know I think we're
trying to change the energy
configuration but it's still the same
logic of mastery
home building technique now we're
without home and I think finding our
home in the homelessness surrendering to
the homelessness might allow us a deeper
kind of intelligence now I'm not saying
we're going to arrive at someplace that
would be pure and true for all eternity
I'm saying the mess is what makes the
real the real and there's no arriving
intact yeah the tree grows crooked out
of the yoke of the planet beautiful
beautifully stated interesting okay how
about the last question um what is most
beautiful in this creation oh this
moment this moment with me and you
sitting down with my brother here in
this place and all the entangled and the
entangling tentacles that made this
moment possible stretching out across
space-time this moment is is is
beautiful this now that is haunted by
ancestors by nonhumans by cameras it's
beautiful thank you thank you
Wow bye oh thank you so much for coming
on the show thank you wow this has been
such an honor
holy cow such an incredible episode
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below and
the episode let us know what you're
thinking on all of the concepts that we
talked about have more conversation to
your friends families co-workers people
online about these subjects that we
talked about you can also find these
subjects in the links in the bio below
again
biyo Aqil melo Lafitte dotnet also
emergence network.org also the Amazon
book link as well check out the books
also the Facebook page check those links
out find these topics there as well get
reading and learning more about them
sharing them as well and also support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
spiritual leaders the organizations
around the world do you believe and
support them and help them grow if you
believe in us you can find all of our
links below help us grow as well and
also go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
peace